hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades the ps4 exclusive days gone had
it behind closed doors playthrough
during e3 but now that footage has
become public this means we can look at
the same mission played in two very
different ways the changes in the
weather the time of day the enemy
layouts the paths taken they're all
dynamic elements that affects your
playthrough with that said let's do this
both variations begin identically with
deacon being told about his mate money
who has been captured by another group
of survivors the original playthrough
looks to be set in springtime on a wet
night whereas the alternative
playthrough takes place in winter esque
weather during the day for future
reference I'm going to refer to these as
spring and winter at this point the
lighting effects are most noticeable and
the slight changes to how the bike
handles although it seems quite similar
probably due to the weather conditions
we also see new hood elements which
appear to be a fuel gauge and the
condition of the bike the first real
difference in gameplay comes at the
point Deacon finds a body on the
roadside initially we saw wolves
feasting on the cops but in the winter
playthrough the warmth an't around and
some opportunistic crows are showing
down instead something this mark has
major impact as deacon is boss the flee
from the world resulting in almost
decapitating himself on a concealed trap
[Music]
switching back to the alternate footage
deacon is not pursued by any animals
giving him just enough time to spot the
trap in the distance he even able to
circle round and ambush those ambushes
here's where the footage converges again
as deacon straight up murders these
fools
Dave's gun must be getting a mature
rating if these brutal murders are
anything to go by both playthroughs have
deacon checking Manny's bike for clues
but in the winter version we are given a
vivid look at what happened a subtle
change to survival vision but enough to
remind us who we are here to save we are
also treated to see the scavenging
element as deacon looter near by
ambulance another difference in the
alternative playthrough are those free
cos deacon encounters on the trail the
cold weather brings our traditional
freaker's and make them stronger too
it also makes them harder to defeat but
in this case Deacon doesn't seem to fade
as we approach the enemy camp the two
playthroughs converge again when Deacon
using a bear trap to mutilate one of the
group what's interesting about this
section is the way the enemy group
reacts to their fallen comrade in the
winter playthrough Deacon sticks around
and witnesses the unlucky chap in the
bear trap being killed by one of his own
group this is due to his screams of pain
in which bring unwanted attention to the
group the survivors cannot take any
chances
and will happily put a bullet in their
own friend in the winter demo we also
see elements of the last of us as deacon
creates a Molotov and takes out those
happy counselors there are many
similarities with the Last of Us but
this looks to be more action orientated
which will be perfect for us who are
waiting for the Last of Us - will you
kill every one of your enemies or will
you sneak past them like Deacon does in
the original demonstration at this point
both playthrough is greatly with deacon
taking two different paths the original
version which is now reached daylight
sees Deacon find a swarm of freaker's
and weaponized them using a makeshift
explosive
oh yeah come and get it at dinnertime
whereas in the alternative version
Deacon slowly makes his way into the
enemy camp first taking out the century
with a frico and then hitting a few
headshots to weaken their rank the
gunplay is looking solid at this point
and the weather effects really add to
the grandeur
[Music]
finally the two versions sync up
perfectly and deacon rescues money I
don't know about you but this game is
looking fantastic in my eyes if we get a
more action focused version of the Last
of Us then I will be a very happy chap
Deacon is looking like an absolute
badass of a lead character and the
variations shown in just this one
mission mode so well for the final game
are you excited for this one let me know
your thoughts below I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time